Well, hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters for another episode of our
Connors and Clinic podcast. Today we have a great guest on. You're going to hear
most, mainly from him. This is Jason Brawl. He is a health educator. He's a
practitioner and author, new book coming out very soon, right?
Jason. Yeah, that's that. That's the hope anyway. Yeah.
Speaker and a filmmaker. And that's really what we're going to talk about a
lot of some of your work with filmmaking, your 2018 kind of documentary, right?
Yeah. The human longevity project. So Jason, I want to jump right into this
and talk about what your latest work is. You've got some new things coming up.
Yeah. So the thing that's most pressing is a summit that I'm hosting called Awakening the
Healer Within, which is going to be launching in October of this year. And this is really getting
to the deeper aspects of of disease. Where does it come from? Where does it really start?
Conversely, where does health come from? Right? And that's really I think a deep
question that is worth exploring. And then how do we ignite that sort of healing response
within the body, right? I mean, very much pertains to cancer, right? We get into these
imbalance states in the body. And yet, and yet there's still something within us
that we can flip. There's something inside us that still holds the magic to healing, right? It's
that same vital force that when you cut your finger somehow has the capacity to heal without you
really doing anything other than setting up the right conditions, right? If you keep
pestering it and badgering it, then it's not going to heal, right? But if you just kind of let the
body do its thing, it's natural wisdom, then it somehow does it on its own. And so that
it's really about getting into the core of that when it comes to any chronic disease that we're dealing with.
So that's the summit that's in October. And then kind of a longer term project. I'm working on
a film series that is exploring ancient and indigenous healing methods from around the world.
So we went into the Himalayas, worked with some Buddhist and bone healers up in the
hype in the mountains. We went to India to work with some Ayurvedic masters there,
went into Peru to work with some shamans in the mountain regions,
and we have plans to go to New Zealand to work with the Maori as well. So there's a lot of
cool things that I'd like to explore to really go beyond, I think, the common threads that we like to
talk about and see if there's some underpinnings that we can bring forth into our modern world.
You and I have to pull this up because you shared something, a quote on your site that I thought was
very intuitive. You said it's more difficult to be healthy in the United States because you have to
do all the work on your own. We've gone astray as a culture because we lost our sense of
community and societal values due to technology. I love that. I want you to kind of
expel down that, if you will. Yeah, I mean, look, this actually goes back to the human longevity
project, the film series that we did where we went around the world to Ikari, Greece, and Sardinia,
Italy, and Okinawa, and Costa Rica. And these are known as blue zones. And the reason that we went
there was because this is where a lot of people make it to a hundred years old. It's an inordinate
number that make it to a hundred in a relatively healthy way. And when I went and visited these
people, what I noticed, even today, was that they lived in these small communal village type settings.
And sure, there's some modern technology, of course, but as I talked to them and I learned about
their past and what life was like growing up in 1940, Ikari, Greece, in this remote island where
in the mountains in Sardinia in 1952, there was no electricity. There was none of the modern conveniences
that we have. Life wasn't so easy in that regard. And so they relied on each other. It was imperative
that they supported one another, that they had connection. You couldn't, not, I mean, right now if I ask
people, do you know your neighbor's names? You know their kids names? Do you know what they do for
a living? Right? We don't really. And the most part, especially in the sort of bigger cities
and in the suburbs. And so we've lost connection with the people that are in our communal areas.
We don't need them, sort of speak, or at least we think we don't. We can do so much on our own,
right? We have computers and technology. I can sit in my house, in my office right now on a podcast
and sneakily order some food on my phone and have it delivered to me. And by the time we're done with
this, have something at my door waiting for me hot, ready to go so I can eat it. We have such amazing
technology that we can fly food around the world. We don't have to work so hard to meet our basic
needs. And because of that, we've lost touch with some of these things that are actually the threads
of what keep us healthy. And we certainly don't have any community interdependence anymore.
Except we freak out as the internet goes down. We don't have those relational interdependence.
You know, we might be dependent upon a technology, but dependent upon our neighbors
and looked for our neighbors to, I mean, even when I was growing up, we ran the neighborhood
every, all of our neighbors from a six block area knew, oh, there's the colors kids and they kind
of looked out for us when we were running around in that area. So there was, even at that time, more
of a community interdependence that today is just completely lost. That's very interesting.
And it's important, right? Like there's a real actual sense of safety, emotionally,
that is actually encoded in our body, right? And this is actually something that we develop as
infants, right? There's a dependence on our caregivers. And so this is actually a developmental process.
If we look at developmental psychology, this act of encoding this level of safety and support
that I can trust, that I can rely on somebody to be there if I need them is actually something
that we're missing. A lot of us miss it or we don't get, we don't get it consistently as children.
And so this actually we carry with us. It's a sort of trauma or a condition actually that we carry
with us. And this actually leads to a strategy that we rely on ourselves and we can actually become
really, really self-reliant in that sense. But inside at the nervous system level,
fundamentally in our entire system, there's a sense of, oh my god, the ship's about to fall. I better
keep this whole thing together. And so that's a really interesting phenomenon when you look at
the West, that we are trying so hard to keep everything together, right? And we don't have the
structures around us that actually can provide that level of support and safety should something fall
apart in my life. Should I lose my job? Should, for whatever reason, I need an amazing and huge expense
on my house that I need to repair. And of course we have insurance companies and we have credit cards
and we have these other things in our sort of modern society that we rely upon if tragedy happens,
if a flood or hurricane rips through my town and all this stuff happens. Sure, we've got these mechanisms.
But in these villages, when I was talking to these people and somebody needed something on their
house reconstructed, the village, the people around would get together, whether it would be pool
money together or actual labor and help them fix or repair or build something that they needed. They
actually, that's a sense of safety built into the community. Now, the reason they did that wasn't
because there were better people than us. It's just that they realized, given their harshness of the
reality that they were living in, that was what was required for them all to survive and to hopefully
thrive. And from a biblical perspective, that is what we're supposed to do as a new testament
church. We're supposed to be the providers of welfare for our community. We're supposed to provide
for the widows and the children and the orphans. Well, now we allow the state to do that and we see
what a horrific job they do in doing that. They might provide some money, but there's no nurture there.
So as we've lost that culture, maybe as you think about it, if you think of in the United States,
do you see that anywhere? Maybe like in a men and a community or an omniscience community,
where there's that close that religious spiritual ties, we might have the best flavor of that
in an example, but yeah, yeah, it's not prevalent. It's exactly right. I think your examples are dead
on. And in fact, in the blue zone work that National Geographic did a while back, they kind of
lumped in Loma Linda, California as a quote unquote blue zone, even though it's not really statistically
a blue zone, but they they wanted to include something in the US to sell more of their publications. But
when we look at that community, and I visited that, it's the same thing because of the seventh day
Adventist, there's a strong communal connection that that is actually held together by values, right? And
so this is what's really important about about any of the religions is that fundamentally there are
values that underlie them, right? And you can choose a handful of them. I mean, I've got some
Mormon friends. That is a tight community, right? So it's really interesting when you look at these
at these societal structures and the way that we organize them, how that provides a level of safety,
a level of support, a level of connection, and ultimately a level of health at the at the fundamental
level at the nervous system level, right? And I think one of the things that's so easy to forget
is that not only can I rely on other people for support, but when I provide support, there's
something that that does to me that is very, very good, right? There's actually really medicine
when I help others, right? And so if we are relying on the state and the bureaucracies and
and all these sort of third parties that that don't really have a human face to them,
then we're actually losing on losing out on that ability to help others and to receive the help.
So there's medicine in both. And so I think it's a it's a thing that I do actually see a resurgence
in this and and look charity is great when we give money away. That's fantastic. There's there's medicine
in that too. But I think there's something deeper that that comes into play when I can actually
help somebody directly, especially if I know them, if they are in my community.
And I see that as a, you talk about the technology that has kind of driven us away. I mean, people
think that they have 5,000 friends because they're Facebook friends. But they really don't know anything
about that person that we become such a narcissistic culture. I heard a statistic that like 10 years
ago, 7.5% of the Americans would be considered narcissistic. And now it's upwards close to
30% and social media was to blame in the article that I read from a psychologist.
I doesn't surprise you're one bit. And I think technology, it's easy to blame technology for all
of our problems. I think and there's a lot to blame. I think where we have an opportunity is to
flip technology on its head and start to make it work for us. I have a friend that that organizes
a charity that they build houses in Mexico. And in large part, they rely on technology to get
the people together to go build houses. Sure. Now these are the things. We can actually, if we just
think a little bit differently about technology, how can I use technology to bring people together
from my local area into a communal dining experience that we can all share? There's so many ways that we
can flip this on its head. Instead of having technology deliver food to my door where I eat it by myself
and I don't have to go out and talk to anybody or touch anything or do anything, let's flip that.
So we just need to get creative with technology. Technology can be a beautiful, beautiful tool for
us to start to bring some of this back into our lives. Well, I love that. That's not at all what we
were going to talk about. That is key. I mean, you talk about healing. I remember I think I posted
a blog post a few years ago, a story I heard of this. This elderly gentleman that was diagnosed
in stage 4 lung cancer and given three months to live. And he decided that he was going to go back.
He was Italian or Greek, I think it was. And he decided to go back to his home, Greek island to live
out the last few months of his life, moved back there. And it was just that. It was this wonderful
cultural thing where all the people in the island grew different things. Everybody had a garden
and then they would come together like a farmer's market, but they would just trade things and they
would all take care of one another. Well, according to my understanding, he's still alive today.
And he lived in the article was written that he had lived years at that point. Never did any treatment.
whatsoever. And just having that community involvement in caring for him and nurturing for him and
just feeling that connection was really his medicine. And we just can't discount that. And I think
so are these other things that are you're getting into in the awake of the healer within
the series? Yeah, definitely. We're talking about a lot of different things, but some of these aspects
that are related to what we might call trauma, because they're certainly trauma. And we know if
we look at Chinese medicine and we look at Ayurveda, we talk about the lungs. That's where we store
grief and sadness. And the libers where a lot of anger and frustration and resentment is held.
So these are real things. How the psychology, how the mindset, how the emotions, how the beliefs
affect our physical biology is very, very real. And for anybody that is doubting that, I want to do
imagine yourself going up on stage and speaking, giving the commencement speech at college graduation.
And you have to deliver this profound speech to thousands. What do you think's going to happen?
You're going to get up there and you're going to start sweating. Your heart's going to start beating.
You're probably going to lose your train of thought unless you're a trained speaker. This is
common. Public speaking is a very, very big fear for many of us. Now why is that? It's not because
we're going to die. Your body says you're going to die, right? Your body is starting to get into
this sympathetic drive of, oh my God, we are in danger. Let's start ramping up all these things,
get blood to the extremities so we can get the heck out of here. But reality is is that there's
something going on and that you're referencing back to childhood, back to your development, that says
that if I screw up in front of this many people, they're not going to like me. They're going to shun
me. I'm not welcome. I can't, we're not going to have connection, right? So I'm being judged. I'm
being criticized. And none of us like being judged or criticized. But this is the internal subconscious
dialogue that is instantly happening for many of us when something like that happens, right? So
these are reference points that we go back that that are still ingrained in our system subconsciously
that that carry this mechanism to start shifting our biology all over the place, right? And so
these conditions that we are raised in that we that we learn to think and believe and feel they're
affecting us as adults. I don't care how old we are. And so yeah, we get into a lot of this type of
thing. How do we unwind that stuff? How do I develop and encode more safety into my body? How do I
find those pieces in those parts that that we're not met correctly as a child and how do I how do I
actually integrate them? So there's a lot of this kind of trauma work. There's a lot of breaking down
old conditioning, old belief systems, old belief structures. And when we do that, we find that
the nervous system starts to get more in balance. The parasympathetic tone starts to increase,
right? The vagus nerve starts to increase. And the vagus nerve is important because it innervates
every all of our internal organs, right? Your liver, your kidney, your pancreas, your spleen,
whole GI tract. So we really rely on the nervous system to be in a good balanced state. So we can
turn on the sympathetic and fight or flight, but it can also drop into this rest and digest and detox
ification and heal mode, which is what we require, no matter what we're healing from, we require that
sympathetic state to be active, right? To be turned on. That's where healing happens, right? And
that's why almost all healing happens during sleep is because so much of us are in sympathetic
drive when we're awake. So we get into a lot of this stuff. We get into some fundamental things,
you know, and digestion and how to improve gut dysfunction and how Ayurveda can show us some new
techniques and tools and things to detoxify, to work with herbs. There's Chinese medicine and
Chigong. There's a lot that goes in, but it's kind of on the periphery, I'd say, then compared to
most functional or integrative medicine type of discussions. Well, that's great. Well,
you're talking about sympathetic slash parasympathetic tone, the autonomic nervous system you're speaking
our language. That's one of the things we measure with our patients, with biometrics and
you can see a person that looks calm as a cucumber on the outside, but their sympathetic parasympathetic
balances is just way off balance. And we as people have learned to kind of stuff our emotions.
So we can't even tell when we're in sympathetic overtone. I just want to pause you there.
That is what you said is so important. This is the thing is that many of us walk through the day
and we think we're calm. But if we measure like you're like you're talking about, we can see, oh,
I'm not calm, but I'm so conditioned. I'm so normalized to this level of nervous system activity
that that's my calm set point. So this is what we don't realize is that, oh, there's a whole
no level of calm. Oh, I didn't realize that. But what does it take for us to get there? That's
the thing. And that's the trick because yes, there's EMFs and there's there's chemicals and metals
and all these things going on physically and biologically in the system. And there's there's other
things that we can't see or taste or touch that are still there that are that are unprocessed emotions
that we're holding onto because either we didn't have the resource because we were five years old
and our nervous system hadn't developed yet. So we literally didn't have that. And when we're young,
by the way, what we rely on is our caregivers nervous system to help us sort of process. And so
we require, we rely on this co-regulation between our caregivers to help us process these things.
I've got a two-year-old son and he absolutely flips out about nothing, loses his mind. And it's
interesting because there's a couple things I notice about that one. He's actually moving these
emotions through. So it's a really, really good thing. I don't want to have him suppress that. I don't
want to teach him to not cry and not lose it. I want to actually provide a level of safety to say,
yes, it's okay that you're losing your mind here over nothing. And here I am, I can help you with this
process, right? On an actual nervous system level. But if I start going crazy on him, then he's going to
learn very soon. This is not okay for me to process this emotion. It's not okay for me to express
anger. It's not okay for me to express frustration and sadness and grief and all these different things.
So we want to actually educate him. And this is a difficult task. I wouldn't say this is easy,
but we want to help him understand. Yes, it's okay that you have these emotions. Not only is it okay.
Here I am in support of you feeling this. Most of us weren't given that. And if we were, we weren't
given it regularly. And so we learn we develop these coping mechanisms, these strategies to bottle
our emotions to hold it in because it's not okay. And so we become very tough on the outside. And we
developed these armors and actually we develop a physical or an energetic armor. This is a very real
thing. And as we go through life, that is protecting us. And what you see with a lot of these people,
and I'm one of them. So I'm not projecting this outward necessarily, is that we develop this
energetic armor. And the first thing that when we face a stressful situation for some of us,
this isn't for everybody, but you'll see this outburst, this anger, this frustration,
that's the first level of emotion that when you're starting to penetrate that armor a little bit,
the anger and this rage starts to come out to protect. And then what you find is that if you can
actually learn to work with the rage and you go, oh, that's anger, that's frustration, that's rage.
And you can actually start to process that instead of projected outward without actually
feeling it, but you can actually process that what you find underneath is sadness, grief,
disappointment, these more tender emotions. So this is what's interesting is that we have all
of these things within us. And in order to to process this backlog of emotions, we've got to feel
them, we've got to go in and we've actually got to sort of experience these things that we never
fully experienced. And there's a lot of them. And there's layers and layers and layers. But the more
we get into that, the more we do that, then we start getting in touch with our feelings, we start
learning how to process them on our own. And then as we do that, this is what starts to reset our
nervous system set point. And we can start to rest in a little bit more of that parasympathetic,
that little bit more that well-being. And so this is a lot of the work that many of us
have the opportunity to do when we when we're dealing with chronic diseases. And I'm speaking
as one of them, I dealt with a lot of chronic issues in my 20s and 30s. And so I'm I'm I finally
realized that that was a big part of the repetitive cycle of chronic symptoms that I was experiencing.
I could make headway and then they come back make headway come back. And that's great. I learned a
lot of techniques and tools. And I figured out a lot of these lifestyle things that I needed to do
as well. And I realized, oh, there's these emotional aspects to these sort of traumas, these
conditions, these these bottled up emotions that I was not allowed to feel. And when I say allowed,
I mean that if my perception as a child was that if I felt these emotions, I wasn't going to get
loved. I wasn't going to get accepted. I wasn't going to get welcomed. And so again, that's a
perception. That's a childlike perception because we don't have a fully developed cognitive system
at that point. So we're just going off of feelings. And if my parent was upset or angry that I
was feeling a certain way, then of course, I want my parents love. I'm going to learn a strategy
to not express that and not make them angry. Right. Now there's a lot that you just said in that
last five minutes. So we've spoken a lot in our clinic about how different organs can okay have cancer
in the liver? Can it be from an anger frustration issue? You have cancer in the colon? Can it be because
you're bottling up things as you're not forgiving and not letting go? So there's all these possible
scenarios. It's a totally different thing to realize that that's a possibility and then be able to
deal with that. So where would people that have a disease of a certain organ or disease of a certain
issue be able to get some of these solutions that you just started to unpack there? Is that the series
that's coming up or do you have a better source for that? Yeah. So we definitely cover a lot of these
techniques and tools and awaken the healer within. So this is the thing about a lot of the summits.
If any of your listeners or viewers have seen a lot of these summits, my one complaint about a lot
of them that are out there is that they talk a lot about theory and a lot about interesting things but
provide little solutions on the deeper levels and that's what I wanted to make sure we did. So we
actually provide the tools, the strategies and the methods of how to actually start to work with some
of these things. And so I'll just give you a couple here just so that your viewers have a little bit
of a taste of what to do in this scenario. A lot of us are unsure what's there. You kind of
mentioned that these things are in the background. We don't really know sometimes we do. Sometimes there's
traumas and there's events that we can recall that we know are significant in our life. And sometimes
we don't know. Most of it I would say we don't know. It's like an iceberg. And so the first place
to start is to get curious. And this is a really important piece. And if I've got liver cancer,
then that's the first place I start. I start to get curious. Do I have frustrations and
angers and resentments? Is that in my doing it? Is that somewhere? And instead of thinking it,
it's like feeling it's like, and you're just searching, you're just this this very gentle curiosity,
right? Childlike. And you can do this in meditation. You can do this in prayer. You can do this in
intention setting and journaling, right? There's a lot of different ways going on a nature walk. I mean,
this is fantastic. This is one of the biggest hacks I can give anybody that's dealing with any
chronic disease is that one of the greatest solutions you can do is just go for a walk outside in
nature. And this is where and this is like a this is like a walking meditation. So not only you're
getting the natural light and the circadian benefits of being outside and and and and
aligning with the rhythms of the day, but you're you're actually moving, right? And this is this will
start the wheels turning and you can start to get curious about some of these things. But but as you get
curious and as these things maybe starting to come up, what you start getting familiar with is that
the solutions don't come from the mind. The mind is just the the reader, the interpreter.
The solutions actually come from within somehow, somewhere, the intuitive aspect of yourself.
There's an emergent quality to a lot of this stuff and a lot of people know what I'm talking about
if they've ever been in the shower and had a great idea, if they're whatever they're doing something
and something hits them or something something just percolates out of nowhere, right? We just kind of
pull these things and that's the state that you want to sort of lose the conditions that you want to
provide so that this emergent quality can come forth. So as you're sitting in meditation, as you're going
on a walk, just getting curious and starting to allow these things to come forward and then as you start
to work with these things or as they start to pop up, then it's a feeling you're starting to get into the
body. This is where the answer is really lies in the body. Your body has the wisdom. So you're starting
to feel these things and you're starting to allow this feeling, this sensation in the body,
whether it's an actual physical sensation in your core and your heart and your back wherever in the body,
but you just start to get curious and start to feel and bring awareness to these aspects in the body.
As you bring awareness to these things in the body, then they start to move and this is this is kind
of the process and I'm sort of short-cutting it here but we actually go through a lot of the step by
step process of this stuff. Sometimes you need to be in the presence of another. Sometimes there's
some things in that we hold on to that require another being to actually help us template or use sort
of mirror neurons to speak to process. And so this is a very well thing especially when it comes to
somatic methods of healing. And so we have these trauma resolution maps or methods that we can use.
There's things like family constellation, there's somatic therapies of various kinds but
the deeper ones typically require another person, a therapist so to speak, but this isn't a talking
therapy. The best therapies actually just work with the body. And there's some like adult attachment
repair model that you can actually hold on to a stick with a therapist not say anything and just
allow your natural awareness, your natural intuitive aspect of both people start to ping each other
and start to work together and you get this co-regulation and all of a sudden you can start feeling these
things happening and these things moving and emotions starting to arise and then you're feeling those
and you're allowed to feel those and then you might start crying and then you start wailing. There's
all kinds of things that can unfold but the key is to start dropping into the body with your awareness
to start feeling these things. And this is a practice for many of us. I couldn't feel things in my
body for a long, long time and when I say that I mean of course I could feel if you hit my knee
and I could feel my body but I wasn't truly in touch with the inner aspects, the inner parts,
the energetic centers in the body. And as I started to feel these things I go oh my god
I've lived my whole life and I've never felt my what they would call Dantean in Chinese medicine
or Chigong. I've never felt my core. How is that possible? So as you get in touch with the deeper aspects
of the body, feeling into the body and starting to feel into this warm fuzzy thing that's happening
inside, not really showing what it is, you're just bringing awareness to it, feeling it, feeling it,
feeling it, gently feeling it. And then things will start to emerge, things will start to shift, things
will start to happen. And so that's really kind of a key but it's a really important key that it's
happening in the body. It's not in the mind, it's not something you have to do. In fact the biggest trick
is to learn to undo, to learn to not do, to learn to just be and allow. And if you can get into
this allow state, this is where the magic happen, this is where your body starts to do things that it
knows how to do. You know we see spontaneous healing's miracles happen in a variety of places. You
know there's a medicine list hospital in China that just uses Chigong. And this is a practice of
developing awareness around the body. And when that happens, energy starts to move, things
start to happen, things start to come alive. The living force that is within you starts to do its
thing. Right. We have a lot of examples of this stuff. And so that's the key to working with some
of these blocked emotions, stuck emotions is to get into the body. And again there's a variety of
ways to do that. Well these are all great techniques. We give people different neurological techniques to
help stimulate parasympathetics or to decrease the mess and stuff a lot of the sympathetic center.
But these emotional techniques that get into the core issues that's what we're all about. So
this is going to be a great series for people. You remind me EMDR is another good tactic as well.
That's a really really good to it. People may be familiar with it that is along those same line.
So there's a lot of cool ways to do it. Right. I mean this is the thing. And to be honest, what I would
tell your viewers and listeners is explore all of them. Whenever's coming your way, whatever lands on
your doorstep and you start getting curious and go, what is this weird thing? He mentioned family
constellation. I don't know what the heck that is. And then you read about it and you go, that sounds
ridiculous and silly and really strange. But then if you try it, you may stumble across something that
opens something up for you where you try EMDR or your guys' techniques. It's like for me, I've become
such a student and such a child about these things. Right. You actually have me super curious about
what the techniques are used. It's like, oh, maybe I haven't tried that. Let me see what's behind
that door. Right. And as you start to do this, instead of taking this really scientific, you know,
methodological approach, you just start going, okay, let me try that. Let me try this. Let me try
that thing over there. And you start doing these things. Role thing is another really good tool to
start working the fascia because the fascia holds a lot of charge, a lot of energy, a lot of emotion.
So as you get into these deeper things like role finger chiropractic work or some of the
massages, you can actually start to loosen some of this stuff that's being held in the body.
The body starts to grip and stiffen. We hold things in our joints and our fascia and our tendons
and our muscles and our bones. This is these are energy stores for all this type of stuff. And so
how do you get it out of the body? That's the big question, right. You start working with a variety
of tools to do that. Well, we talk a lot about that everything is a frequency and you have to get to
that level if you really want to heal. Exactly. Well, we're going to give links to your current
docu series that you have out there. The longevity project project, but we're also going to give
links to the one that's coming up. And by the time this podcast gets aired, it will be out.
So we want everybody to dive into this with that like you say, Jay, so that healthy curiosity that
just opens up their mind and say, okay, what does God have for me here? How can I learn something else?
And like we say with every disease process, we view that as this huge negative, but it can be viewed
as a huge positive learning tool. What do I need to learn about my body through this? What does God
try to teach me? Let's see it in a different light. It can be very beneficial. Yeah, I think that's
what you ultimately land upon as you go through any healing process. When you kind of get over this
hump or you get to the other side, so to speak, you go, oh my God, thank God that happened.
Because that's the thing that I needed in order to make these changes. And so, you know, we humans
are silly creatures. And then we sometimes need to go through the muck in order to figure out where's
my alignment. And this is really what it's about. It's like, how do I align with my constitution,
with my system, right? Because we are all individuated aspects of the one all, right? So, but I'm
unique. I'm very unique to you. So how do I work with my system? Who am I inside? I mean, this is the
ultimate question that we continue to come back to anyway. And so all this stuff is just helping us
learn about me, my system. What do I need to do in this stage of my life? And then there's the other
aspect, which is how do I align with the greater whole, right? And this is when we talk about circadian
rhythms and sleeps, there's universal principles, right? A connection. There's these things that we
that are true no matter who we are, right? Eating organic food is always going to be true better than
eating pesticide laden food, right? Eating something that is grown in really healthy soil is always
going to be better than something that has grown in soil that is devoid of microbes and life, right? So
there's universal aspects. We need to chew our food thoroughly, right? It's a very simple one
that we skip over. And we just start, okay, let me just chow my food and take these enzymes and these
probiotics and we think that's going to do it. No, no, no, there's universal truth. So how do I
align with the greater whole? How do I align with myself? And when you start doing that, then good
things start to unfold. Yeah. Well, we want to have you back if you'd be willing to. And while we're
still recording, I want you to say yes to that. Totally. Yeah, I'm totally down a little talk about
you did touch on circadian rhythm and sleep. And that's an important thing for anybody dealing with
chronic disease. So maybe next time we'll touch on that. Yeah, I'd love to. That's a it's a one of my
favorite topics. And it's something when I work with people as a practitioner, it's the first thing that
we that we really look at is do we have this in in in alignment? And if it's not, then this is where we
start. Right. So again, thank you to my guest, Jason. Paul, we're going to have his information
up here so everybody can get to his website and see the tools that he has there. And we always say
the more tools that you have in your tool, make the better off you're going to be able to do it,
building the house that you need to build. So again, thank you, Jason. I appreciate it. Thanks for
having me. And we'll talk again very soon. Yeah, I hope so. All right.